[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه بابرز عناوينها
ايران
التعسفيه لقمع الاحتجاجات
وفي ملفات الخامسه طرود مفخخه تستهدف
سفاره الامريكيه ومكتبه لاتحاد الاوروبي
في مدريد واسبانيا تعزيز اجراءات الامن
وفي ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه صفارات
الانذارات تدوي في كفه انحاء اوكرانيا
والدفاع الروسيه تعلن التقدم في اقليم
دانيسك
ولدينا ايضا تزيد مباشره العمليه البريه
التركيه شمال سوريا وانقره تطالب الجوار
بابعاد المجموعات المسلحه
الايرانيه فقط قال الصحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه ان الحكومه الايرانيه صعدت من
جهودها لاختطاف وقت المسؤولين الحكوميين
المنشقين الذين فروا من البلاد والنشطاء
والصحافيين في جميع انحاء البلاد بما في
ذلك في الولايات المتحده وذلك وفقا لوثائق
حكوميه ومقابله مع خمسه عشر مسؤولا في
واشنطن واوروبا وشرق الاوسط نشرتها صحيفه
واشنطن حيث اوضح المسؤولون الغربيون ان
اجهزه المخابرات والامن الايرانيه تعتمد
الى حد كبير على الوكلاء لتنفيذي خططهم
كما تقدم مئات الالاف من الدولارات للوصوص
المجوهرات وتجار المخدرات وغيرها من
المجرمين لتنفيذ مخططات القتل المسؤولون
الغربيون اكدوا على ان اسرار ايران على
قتل المستقيم من شانه ان يؤدي الى مواجهه
مباشره
نفسه تعهد قائد الحرس الثوريه سلامي
المحتاجين مشددا على عدم السماح لاحد
باستهداف ما اسمه امن واستقرار الشعب قائد
الحرس الثوري اضاف في تصريحات الرسميه ان
قوه الحرس مستعده لتضحي بنفسها من اجل
النظام تصريحات سلامي تاتي عقب تهديدات
سابقه من مرشدي ايران للمتظاهرين
هذا ويوصل المحتاجون في ايران تحدياهم
للقمع الامني والعسكري بالاضافه الى رفض
التحذيرات شديده اللهجه من قبل السلطات
والتي يعتبرها المتظاهرون تخويفيه فطلاب
الكليات التقنيه بجامعهران اعلن بدء خوض
اضراب عام بالاضافه الى اعتصام عام
بالتزامن مع المطالبه باطلاق صراحه طلاب
المعتقلين في هذا الوقت يلجا النظام
الايراني للاقاله التعسفيه بحق من يشارك
في التظاهرات او نقل وتغيير مناصب
الموظفين الذين شاركوا في الاحتجاجات كما
شننت السلطاته حمله تغير واسعه في صفوف
العاملين في الدوائر الحكوميه في المدن
الكرديه في خطوه وصفت بالانتقاميه فيما
كشف التقارير ايرانيه عن اعتقالات نفذها
النظام طالت قاده بالحركه الثوري لتناولهم
التفاصيل مقتل الشابه ماسه على عناصر
الامن في سبتمبر الماضي وقال موقع سحامي
يوز ان عناصر الامن داهمت منزله احد كبار
قاده الحائط الثوريه محمد باقر بختار
واعتقلته وصادرت متعلقاته الشخصيه ونقلته
الى مكان مهجول وكان بختار قد نشر في وقت
سابقا ملفا صوتيا وقال ان سلطات تحاول
التستر على مقتل محسن التي توفيت بسبب
ضربات على الجمجمه حسب وصفه كما انتقد عدم
تحمل النظام لمسؤوليته عن قتل امين واصفا
السلطه في ايران بالفاقده لهويتها وفقا
لتعبيره
وينضم الينا من اصله وعضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه عمار تسائي مرحبا بك
سيد عمار يوما بعد يوم يزداد القمع يزداد
الاستهداف وهناك تقارير ايضا دوليه تشير
الى ان ما يحدث ربما يؤدي الى مواجهه ما
بين الدول الغربيه وايران هل يمكن ان يحدث
ذلك بالفعل
هذا يرجع الى المقاربه الامريكيه
والاوروبيه تجاه ايران فاذا ما
لانه ما اطلق من تهديدات ضد الصحفيين
والناشطين في الخارج هذا ليس جديدا وحتى
نظام الايراني اقامه
بتصفيات لمعرضين ولسياسيين في اوروبا وفي
امريكا في السابق وهذا همم لا يمكن ان
يكون خفيا على اجهزه مخابرات هذه الدول
اما القرار السياسي اعتقد ان ذلك يعت- اا
يرجع الى المقاربه الموجوده لدى همم
امريكا والدول الاوروبيه ايران التي يبدو
انها همم بدات تتغير من من التوازن
الاستراتيجي او همم الوقود والحصول على
الوقود خاصه في هذه الظروف الى تغيير
النظام بعد ما لمست
الشعوب الايرانيه لتغيير النظام واستبداله
بنظام الديمقراطي اعتقد ان هذه الدول اي
الدول الغربيه غيرت نظرتها وسوف تغير ايضا
استراتيجيتها ااا اتجاه النظام الايراني
اسالك عندما يتم الحديث عن ايقاف عدد من
المسؤولين في الحرس الثوري نفسه للادلاء
بمعلومات حول مقتل مساميني او المشاركه في
هذه التظاهرات هل يواجه النظام الايراني
ما يشبه التمرد داخل ارحاره الثوري ام انه
من المبكر الحديث عن هذا الامر
هذه الانبا اعتقد انها بدايه تصدع في جدار
النظام الامني والعسكري وما قيل حول هذه
هؤلاء الضباط في الحرس الثوري والحرس
الثوري هو يعتبر الركيزه الاساسيه للقوه
الامنيه للنظام الايراني فاعتقد ان ذلك هو
بدايه
التصدع الذي يخشاه النظام ولذلك نراه
يتخبط حاليا بين خطوات
فشلت للان جميعها مثلا مره يعول على كره
القدم ويصرف الملايين حسب الاخبار التي
وصلت الينا او تداولتها الصحف الايرانيه
انه صرف
الدولارات لارسال او للايفاد مشجعين الى
كاس العالم في قطر وايضا رصد ميزانيه
للاحتفال ولكن الفريق الايراني خسر امام
الاولى
ده هو اليوم نرى رئيس ابراهيم رئيس يسافر
الى كردستان والى سننتج
عاصمه وايضا ايضا اعتقد ان هذه السفرجات
لكي تهدئ الامور ولكي تبدو الامور عاديه
لانه قيل في ال- في الصحافه الايرانيه
صحافه النظام انه ذهب ليدشر مشروع مياه
ولكن الصور التي تداولتها همم وكالات
انباء النظام تدل ان على اب- انه هناك فقط
مجموعه صغيره قامت باستقبال همم رئيس
الامريكيه من ان ايران تستهدف المنشقين
والمعارضين ليس بالقمع في الدخل فقط ولكن
ايضا بالاستهداف على اراضي دول الاخرى
ومنها الولايات المتحده ما خطوره هذا
المتغير فيما يتعلق بتعامل واشنطن مع
وغيرها من الدول بالطبع مع ايران
طبعا هذا هو يعني واحد او جزء من كل اعتقد
ان الاداره الامريكيه تعرف هذا الشيء جيدا
وتعرفه حتى قبل ان تبدا هذه
الثوره ولكن كانت بناء نوعا ما تتعامل
مع بشيء من المرونه خاصه الديمقراطيين
يتعاملون مع هذا
المرونه املا في التوصل الى حال في قضيه
الملف النووي ولكن الان بعد ما حدث حدث
هذه الثوره اعتقد ان سوف يكون موقفا اخرا
واشنطن ازاء هذا الموضوع خاصه وان هناك
مسؤول امريكي صرح قال انه الخيار العسكري
ايضا مطروح ومطروح همم لمواجهه ايران او
في هناك امكانيه لهذا الخيال للاستخدام
هذا اعتقد انه موقف واشنطن لم يعد كما كان
قبل الثوره واح حتى من قبل الديمقراطيه
الذين هم اكثر مرونه سوف يكونون اكثر
جلديه وسراميط
تسائي تحياتي
وفي تطور جديد في اسبانيا او عز وزير
الداخليه بتشديد الاجراءات الامنيه
بالمنشات العامه والدبلوماسيه بعد العثور
على عده طروب مفخخه داخليه الاسبانيه ذكرت
ان الطرود المضبوطه ارسلت من داخل البلاد
مشيره الى عدم وجود اسباب كافيه حتى الان
لاعلان الانذار من خطر الارهابي الى ذلك
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي ضبطه طرد مفاخ في
احد مكاتبه باسبانيا فيما تلقت السفاره
الامريكيه رساله شبيهه بالطرود المفخخه
السابقه وذلك بتزامن مع ضبط اخر في مقر
وزاره الدفاع بالعاصمه مدريد وكان الامن
الاسباني عبر امس على طرديني وفخخين
احدهما انفجر بمقار السفاره الاوكرانيه
بمدريد والثاني في احدى الشركات المصنعه
للاسلحه
وانضم الينا من بون جاسم محمد رئيس المركز
الاوروبيه لدراسه مكافحه الارهاب
والاستخبارات مرحبا بك سيد جاسم هل نحن
امام تطور خطير يقول ان الحرب مع بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا يمكن ان تمتد الى ليس فقط
عمليات عسكريه في الداخل ولكن الى عمليات
ارهابيه في الخارج تستهدف حلفاء اوكرانيا
وصفت بنا حرب هجينه وهذا يعني بانه ممكن
جميع الادوات نحن نتحدث عن الحرب
التقليديه الاسلحه التقليديه وكذلك
التهديد باستخدام السلاح النووي التكتيكي
وكذلك الاستراتيجيه اه هيك عن الاسلحه
البايولوجيه واسلحه الدمار الشامل فاذا
الحروب الاستخبارات وحروب ايضا الارهاب
همم داخل الدول اوروبا ممكن ان يكون هنالك
يتوجهها جديد الى جماعته تشتغل حرب
اوكرانيا بتنفيذ مثل هذه العمليات فاذن
بالرغم لكن بالرغم
ان الدلال والشواهد تقول بانها هي تستهدف
ربما او ربما تقدم جماعات معارضه الى
الحرفانيه لكن اجدها هي ليست بعيده بصراحه
عن الوضع الامني والسياسي في اسبانيا
هنالك حراك يميني وهنالك ايضا حركه ايتا
الانفصاليه
واجد انه الوضع السياسي والامني في
اسبانيا هو ليس بعيد خاصه
لماذا اسبانيا تحديدا وحضرتك اجبت ولكن
السؤال الان يتعلق ايضا بحجم هذه المساله
ومن يقف ورائها هل نحن نتحدث عن جماعه
المعارضه للحرب في اوكرانيا ان نتحدث عن
طرف رئيسي في هذه المعركه وهي روسيا ربما
الماضي يعتقد ان تمت اليه جديده يتم الرد
بها على اغتيالي همم شخصيه بارزه كانت
قريبه من بوتين
فشلت عمليه الاغتيال وتم اغتيال ابنته
ولكنه كان كاتب مساند لبن
الخيارات تبقى مفتوحه وفي باب التحليل
ناخذ جميع الخيارات اذا كانت الاتهامات
الى روسيا هذا يبقى خيار القائم لكن نحتاج
الى شواهد والادله لكن هنالك ربما يعني
كون انه يعني الطرود جاءت من داخل اسبانيا
وهنالك وضع امني متازم ايضا سياسي واملي
داخل اسبانيا ممكن ان يخفف من هذا الاتهام
الى روسيا لكن هو يبقى قائمه في موضوع
التحليل الاخر انه هنالك بصراحه مثل هذا
النوع من الطرود اكيد تحتاج الى خبره وهذا
يعني بانها ليست جماعه سادس جوانا جماعه
متمرسه في موضوع التطرف او الارهاب وهذا
يعني انه ممكن ان تكون مؤشر الاتهام تكون
الى عناصر يمنيه متطرفه ايضا داخل اسبانيا
لها علاقه ربما
في تقديم الدعم ال همم
اخواني الى اوكرانيا
لماذا لم تصعد السلطات الاسبانيه من درجه
التحذير الى درجه مخاطره كبيره تتعلق
بعمليات ارهابيه هل لان هذه العمليات تبدو
صغيره بعض الشيء ولم تؤدي الى نتائج او
تدعايات خطيره
حتى حجم التفجير الذي يحدث هذا الطرد هو
محدود جدا وهنالك اجراءات بسيطه هي ممكن
ان تعتبرها الاجهزه الامنيه بشكل بسيط هي
الفحص بالاشعه السينيه وكذلك الفحص
الفيزيائي ممكن ان يتجنب يعني همم يعني
دوائر البريد
والديكال وغيرها في ديكس من الشركات التي
تقوم بنقل هذه الطرود ممكن ان تقوم بفحصها
فائزه انه رفع حاله الانذار يثير ربما له
تداعيات هذه تداعيات ممكن ان تكون تدا لا
تبنيه تداعيات سياسيه فلذلك جئت انه ليس
في وارد الان الحكومه الاسبانيه من دون
السيد جاسم محمد رئيس المركز الاوروبي
لدراسته مكافحه الارهاب والاستخبارات
تحياتي
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ولدينا
المنتخب المغربي وجهه بعد قليل نظيره
الكندي في مباراه حاسمه للتاهل الى دور 16
[موسيقى]
واعيله ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
والتشابكاته الدوليه حتى رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارلي ميشيل الرئيس الصيني في
جيل بنك على استغلال نفوذه للضغط على
روسيا لاحترام ميثاق الامم المتحده فيما
يتعلق باوكرانيا واضاف منشيل ان رئيس
الصينيه اكد بوضوح انا بكين لا ترسل اسلحه
الى روسيا ومن جهته اكد رئيس الصينيه على
ان بكين ستواصل تعزيز الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه والتنسيق مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي
هو في الملف الاوكرانيه ايضا طلب وزير
الخارجيه دمتري كليبا بضروره ان تتضمن
حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه المقبله قطاع
انتاج الصواريخ الروسيه واضاف كل بانه اكد
لمفوض السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل اهميه ايقاف صناعه الصواريخ
الروسيه كما اشار الى انه اتفق مع برج على
ضروره تقديم الدعم الكامل لاوكرانيا في
مواجهه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
بدوره قال الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
عنبرجه خلال مشاركته في مؤتمر برلين للامن
قال انه على دول الحلفان تعيد تقييم
اعتمادها على الدول لاسترداديه على حد
وصفه فيما يتعلق بمصادره الطاقه او بمصادر
الطاقه وسلاسل التوريد
الروسي يجب ان يقودنا هذا الى اعاده تقييم
اعتمادنا على الدول الاستبداديه الاخرى
ليس اقلها الصين بالنسبه لسلاسل التوريد
والتكنولوجيا والبنيه التحتيه
سنواصل بالطبع التجاره
اقتصاديا مع الصين لكن علينا ان نكون على
درايه بتبيعاتنا وان نقوم بتقليل نقاط
ضعفنا واداره المخاطر
على الجانب الاخر قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سريع الابراج ان التوسع حلف الناتو
شرقا خط احمر مشيرا الى ان الغريزه
الاساسيه للامريكيين ودول النت الاخرى لم
تختفي ابدا وهي غريزه التوسع على حد خوله
[موسيقى]
ان الغربه في ذلك الوقت قد وقع على هذا
النوع من الشعارات متوقعين ان بلدنا لن
يستعيد مكانته ابدا في اوروبا او على
مستوى العالم وان يعيش العالم وفقا
لقواعدها الديمقراطيه الليبراليه
التي لم تختفي ابدا بالنسبه للامريكيين
ودول النيه الاخرى تفسر مسار التوسع
المتهور لحلف النيدو والذي يقلل من المعنى
الرئيسي لمنظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا
كادت جماعيه لتوفير الامن المتكافئ وغير
القابل للتجزئه ويقلل من قيمه الوثائق
التي تم قبولها في منظمه الامن والتعاون
في اوروبا وتسعينات
اه
وهننتقل الى واشنطن لمتابعه استقبال
الرئيس الامريكي جوبيدن لنظيره الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون في البيت الابيض هذه
الصور تاتين للزياره الثانيه لمكرون الى
واشنطن منذ توليه رئاسه في فرنسا وهي
الزياره الاولى له في عهد الرئيس
هذه الزياره يتم التعويل عليها كثيرا هناك
اهتمام في الاوصاف الاعلاميه الامريكيه
بهذه الزياره خاصه مع حملته عناوين بعض
الصحف الامريكيه من ان ثم تتوتر كبير في
العلاقه الامريكيه الفرنسيه ولكنها وصفت
هذا التوتر بانه التوتر مكتوم بسبب العديد
من الاجراءات الامريكيه اخرها قانون يتعلق
بدعم
للمنتجات الامريكيه لمواجهه التضخم ما ادى
الى تداعيات سلبيه بالطبع على المنتجات
الاوروبيه وجعل ماكرون في لقائه مع عدد من
اعضاء الكونجرس بالامس يصف هذا القانون
بالعداء كانت ايضا تصريحات لمكرون قد وصفت
ما تقوم به امريكا من تحديد سعر الغاز
باسعار عاليه هو يمثل ايضا تحديا كبيرا
للدول الغربيه مع ازمه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على اي حال تترقب كل الاوساط
هذا اللقاء وما سيسفر عنه من قضايا
ومناقشات ولكن تصريحات سابقه كما تقول
وسائل الاعلام لماكرون تقول ان هذا اللقاء
سيكون لقاءا صعبا يحمل عناوين تتعلق بما
يبدو من توتر مكتوب
رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون كان قد
اعتبر ان الولايات المتحده واوروبا ليست
على قدم المساواه بسبب الدعم الامريكي
الذي تنص عليه خطه حول المناخ والتي تعطي
اولويه للمنتجات المصنوعه محليا وهو ما
اشير او اشرنا اليه منذ قليل بقانون سمي
بقانون مواجهه التضخم وقع عليه رئيس
الامريكي بتقديم الدعم كبير للمنتجات
الامريكيه هذا الامر يشغل بال مكروب بشكل
كبير في هذه الزياره
سنبقى في متابعه هذه الزياره لمكرون الى
البيت الابيض ولكن نذهب الى الكريم الان
فقد ادانا دعوه من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
عقدي محكمه جرائم حرب بشان الحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وقال الكريم ان اي هيئه سيتم
تاسيسها ستكون غير شرعيه ولن تقبلها موسكو
ما في اخر التطورات الميدانيه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه السيطره على منطقه
مع استمرار المعارك العنيفه ضد القوات
الاوكرانيه وذكرت الوزاره ان ماذا يقل عن
40 جنديا اوكرانيا قتلوا في معارك
اندرافيكا من جهه اخرى قصفت القوات
الاوكرانيه مناطقه وسط دونيس ب 290 قذيفه
وصاروخ خلال 24 ساعه
الى ذلك اصدرت السلطات الاوكرانيه تنبيهات
واعلنت حاله الانذار الجويه في جميع انحاء
البلاد وذلك تحسبا لموجه جديده من الغارات
الروسيه بالصواريخ والمسيرات وقال مسؤولون
اوكرانيون ان حاله الانذار شامله وتمت
دعوه جميع المواطنين الى النزول للمنازل
العربيه على الارض من قيام راس العربيه
الزميل حذيفه عادل وينضم الينا ايضا من
تونس كاس زميل رائد الاخضر مرحبا بكم الى
هذه النشره نبدا من اكياف كان هناك تقرير
لك حذيفه رصد بالصوت والصوره ما تتعرض له
البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه وخاصه في مجال
الكهرباء من تدمير كبير من قبل القوات
الروسيه هذا ادى الى تداعيات خطيره دعنا
في الصوره حول اخر التطورات
نعم تحياتي في الحقيقه الوضع صعب جدا يعني
في اوكرانيا في كييف العاصمه وفي جميع
المدن طبعا يمكننا ان نقسم نسبه الخطر من
وسط البلاد وسط وشمال وغرب البلاد يختلف
الوضع طبعا عن جنوب وجنوب شرق وشرق البلاد
الوضع هناك اكثر تعقيدا خاصه في المناطق
القريبه من خط النار همم في الحقيقه
العاصمه كيف فقط يعني حوالي 20% تقريبا من
المشتركين همم
يعجز النظام الطاقه عن مدهم همم حتى هذه
اللحظه
بالخدمه همم بشكل عام اا النظام في
اوكرانيا همم يشكل عجز بنسبه 27 في المئه
همم اكثر من 10 مليون مشترك في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيهم خارج همم
شبكه الكهرباء نتيجه الضربات الصاروخيه
التي نفذت لمحطات الطاقه في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا الوضع ما زال متعزما القطاعات
الكهرباء تستمر لخمسه ساعات يو هذا في
الظروف الطبيعيه اما اذا زادت هذه الضربات
او اذا حدثت اي اعطال اعطار تزيد نسبه
القطوعات الى 10 واحيانا الى اكثر من ذلك
ساعات طبعا خلال اليوم همم بشكل دائم الان
بدا المواطنين يعتمدون بشكل اكبر على
مولدات الطاقه طبعا تعلمين ان هناك عمليات
دعم الان همم
لاصلاح نظام الطاقه هذه
المساعدات من الاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه بعد
الاجتماع الاخير الذي التامى في بوخارسلي
وزراء خارجيه دول حلف همم
اعلنت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن 53
مليون دولار مساعدات قبل كانت فرنسا قد
قدم 18
القوات الروسيه اليوم او دخولها لاول مره
الى مدينه او منطقه دونيسكي في الاقليم
الكبير اقليم دونيس كيف حدث هذا التقدم
يعني
سخونه بالغه حيث ان القوات الروسيه تمكنت
من دخول بلدات على اطراف
شمال المقاطعه كما اسلفت اندريه بلده
المناطق الجنوبيه من مدينه تشهد يعني قتال
شوارع ما بين قوات ما بين الروسيه
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه تحاول دفع
الجيش الاوكراني للانسحاب من هذه المدينه
لانها مدينه استراتيجيه وهي قريبه على مدن
كرامته همم
بالفعل هناك محاوله تطويق من ناحيه
الجنوبيه
الغربيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه لهذه المدينه
وتكثف القوات الروسيه وجودها في هذه
المنطقه اللي اثبات اي انتصار على الارض
ايضا
هل هناك ما يشبه انت تلاحظ على الارض من
فمه تقدم من حقيقي للقوات الروسيه
اشبه برفعه شطرنج حيث تتواجد القوات
الاوكرانيه وتواجد القوات الروسيه وكذلك
المواليه لروسيا من ناحيه اخرى المناطق
الجنوبيه تحاول القوات ايضا المواليه
لروسيا التقدم لكن هناك يعني هجوم مضاد من
قبل الاجانب الاخراني دون القريبه من
مدينه ايضا يعني تحاول القوات المواليه
لروسيا السيطره عليها وهنا قتال شوارع في
هذه المدن اليوم
تلقت منذ صباح الباكر رشققات من الصواريخ
الجراج استهدفت المدينه
الى المداهمات والاقتحامات الكبيره اطراف
المقاطعه ما بين همم مقاطعات خارجه هي
فعل ساخنه جدا لكن روسيا
الميداني يمكن القول بان بان دانيت هي
الوحيده التي يح
رز هذا عنوان ايضا
ان اقليم دونيسكو والاقليم او المنطقه
التي تحرض فيها القوات الروسيه تقدما حتى
هذه اللحظه الشكر لزملائي حذيفه عادل من
كتاب وايضا رائد الاخضر
الرومانسيه لرويترز تقول انا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتفقوا على سقف سعر الغاز او سعر
النفط عفوا الروسي عند 60 دولار يشير الى
العشر مره اخرى مصادر الدبلوماسيه تشير
الى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يوافقوا بالفعل
على وضعه سقفا لسعر ان نفطر الروسي عند
ستينا»
تدريبات عسكريه كثافه قد تخضع لها القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا الشتاء في ظل الهدوء
النسبي الذي يخيم على الحرب الاوكرانيه
بسبب دخول فصل الشتاء الذي يصعب العمليات
العسكريه على الارض التدريبات اقتراحاتها
كييف على الحليفه واشنطن والتي تدرس
الموضوع بتعاوني مع المانيا
حرب اوكرانيا الساخنه تدخل الشتاء باردا
قد تلجم ثلوجه حده المعارك الهدوء النسبي
على الجبهات فرصه للطرفين الاوكراني
والروسي لتعزيز قدراتهم العسكريه
شبكه سي ان ان نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ان اداره بايدن تدرس توسيع تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا الشتاء بناء على طلب كيف
منذ بدايه الصراع في فبراير الماضي دربت
الحليفه واشنطن عده الاف من الجنود
الاوكران في مجموعه صغيره الا ان
التدريبات المتوقعه ستكون اوسعه كما ونوعا
واكثر شمولا وكثافه لكيفيه العمل في تكوين
العسكريا متماسك
نبحثوا باستمرار عن طرق للتاكد من ان
الاوكرانيين لديهم المهارات التي
يحتاجونها للنجاح في ساحه المعركه حيث
تدافع اوكرانيا عن اراضيها من العدوان
الروسي
منذ بدايه الحرب تتعاونوا المانيا مع
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا لتقديم
التدريب للقوات الاوكرانيه وفي حال
الموافقه الامريكيه على نظام التدريب
الجديد ستكون قاعده فراجين فور العسكريه
في المانيا هي التي تطلع اليها القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه نظرا لحاجه التدريبات
الى مجموعه اكبر واكثر تنوعا من المدربين
وقت المستقبل
في العام 2023
اكثر من 300,000 تم التدريبهم في اكثر من
100 ساحه التدريب في روسيا بلا روسيا كما
تم انشاء ساحه تدريب جديده ومتعدده
الانواع في اقليم ايرسك
لكن المحللين يطرحون اسئله حول مدى اهميه
التدريبات العسكريه تلك في ساحه المعركه
كون الصراع تم خوضه في الاساس كحرب
استنزاف طاحنه بين جيشين مدفعيه مما يجعل
المتغير الاساسيه في الحرب الان هو كم
الذخيره المتوفره لدى الطرفين الى عمر
العربيه
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ولدينا
ماسك لتفهم ما فعلته روسيا تعالى الى
اوكرانيا
اهلا بكم من جديد نذهب الان الى العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن لمتابعه كلمه الرئيس
الامريكي
خلال استقباله لرئيس الفرنسي
وهاب سكينه
في الثوره ومساعده الامريكيين والتي ساعدت
في
عمليتها في نورمان
الحريه اليوم هذا شعار
يزداد فريقا اكثر من اي وقت مضى والتحالف
بين البلدين يبقى اساسيا من اجل دفاعنا
المشترك
نينوى
بالتعاوني مع شركائنا الاخرين ومجموعه
الدول السبعه فان فرنسا والولايات المتحده
ت- تواجهني سويا
طموحي بوتن الدموي وحربه الوحشيه ضد
اوكرانيا التي تظهر مره اخرى
مدى الخطر الذي تتعرض له اوروبا
دوت كوم
[موسيقى]
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان العالميه التي
تكمن في صميمها
العالم شهد الالتزام المشترك لدينا في
تحقيق العداله والحريه
لكافه الاطراف
بتقول
اتت بكلها من خلال هذه القياده المشتركه
وبحكم الشراكه الاثيقه التي تجمع هنا
ويمكننا مع فرنسا ان نتعامل في التصدي
لتغير المناخي من اجل تامين حياه كريمه
للاجيال القادمه وكذلك انا اود ان نعيد
تاكيد التزامنا
لانهائي هذه الازمه في حلول عام 2000
وثلاثين
المكرام
عن نقطه
اصطدام من تعرضنا لها في التاريخ وكيف
اتخذنا الخيارات المناسبه وكيف للخيارات
المستقبليه ان ترسم ملامح المستقبل
والعالم والولايات المتحده لا يمكنها ان
تطلب شريك افضل اكثر من فرنسا فعلى مر
عقود من الزمن اجتمعنا سوريه واخترنا
طريقا نحو الحريه ونحو الفرس الاعظم ومن
اجل تامين الكرامه والسلام
مبابي
[موسيقى]
اليوم بين الطلاب
شعوبنا سوف تبقى مستمره للعقود المقبله
السيد الرئيس نرحب بك مجددا ونرحب بالوفد
الفرنسي انه لشرف كبير ان استضيفكم هنا
واتطلع الى يوم جميل لنا فليبارك الله في
دولنا فل يحمي الله قواتنا السيد الرئيس
[موسيقى]
الفرنسي ايمانويل
ديموقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
هذه هي الكلمه التي سيلقيها الان الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون والتي تعد اول او
يعد اول زياره يقوم بها مكروم منذ توالي
بيض الحكم ولكنه كان قد ظهر الولايات
المتحده مرتين منذ رئاسته فرنسا ولكن هذه
المره الاولى التي يقوم بها بزياره واشنطن
في عهد بيضه
والى ملف العمليه العسكريه المرتقبه
لتركيا طلبه الولايات المتحده تركيا اعاده
تقييم خطوطها بشان العمليه البريه في شمال
سوريا وقال وزير الدفاع تركيا
والكف عن تسليح مجموعات المسلحه وحضر اكار
الدول الحليفه من التلك في ابعاد
المجموعات المسلحه عن اراضيها قطع جميع
العلاقات معها في اقرب وقت ممكن
وينضم الينا من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو مرحبا بك زيدان كانت هناك
انباء عن اجتماعا لمجلس الامن القومي
التركي لاتخاذ القرار وساعه الصفر بالنسبه
للعمليه العسكريه التركيه البريه المرتقبه
هل من تفاصيل حول هذا الامر
قبل حوالي ساعه ونصف الساعه من الان ما
زال الاجتماع مستمر
ويناقش الاجتماع برئاسه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان عده ملفات من ابرزها طبعا ملف
العمليه العسكريه طبعا القرار النهائي همم
ربما لن يتخاف بهذا الاجتماع يعني حتى
الان الامور غير واضحه لان الاتصالات
الدبلوماسيه بين انقره وعدد من العواصم
اللاسيمه موسكو واشنطن ما زالت مستمره لكن
الاجتماع استناقش كل التفاصيل يعني شكل
العمليه
بناءا على المواقف الدوليه هل سيكون هناك
عمليه في الاصل في حاجه كان هناك رفض دولي
كبير لهذه العمليات نطاق العمليه هل هي
فعلا في ثلاثه محاور كما تحدث الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان همم صادقا منبج وترفعت وعين
العرب امس تكون في نطاق عمليه محدوده
ولمنطقه واحده وربما ستكون في هذه الحاله
اذا اختار تركي القيام بعمليه محدوده ربما
ستكون في رفعت في ريف حلب الشمالي والقرى
المحيطه بها كل هذه التفاصيل
الظروف الدوليه والنفاق العمليه والتوقيت
والزمان
سيتم مناقشته في هذا الاجتماع الذي انطلق
قبل ساعه او اكثر من ساعه على وجه التحديد
طبعا وزير الدفاع التركي وقبل الانضمام
الى الاجتماع كان له تصريح صحفي ذكرتمو
قبل قليل انتقل فيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والدعم الامريكي وحدات الحمايه
الكرديه والمسلحين الافراد وطالب همم
الجانب الامريكي بالوفاء بالتزاماته
وتعاهداته همم عندما همم في المقابل
الولايات المتحده او الجانب الامريكي طلب
من همم تركيا اعاده دراسه موضوع العمليه
بالعمر
من اسطنبول
في غضوري ذلك افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان بدخول قوافل تابعه للتحالف الدولي
ضد داعش تحمل اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه من
اقليم كردستان العراق الى شمال وشاق سوريا
خلال اليومين الماضيين وقال المرصد ان
القوافل التي دخلت الاراضي السوريه من
معبر الوليد الحدودي تالفت من اكثر من 240
شاحنه تحمل على متنها مدافع واسلحه رشاشه
ثقيله ومعدات عسكريه وذخائر اضافه الى
صهاريج وقود خطف المرصد ان القوافل توجهت
الى قواعد ان التحالف الدولي في محافظه
الحسكه
بعد شهرين على اطلاق رجل الاعمال
الامريكيه لهم ماسك مقترح خطه سلام
لاوكرانيا تضمنت التنازل عن اراضي لروسيا
رد رئيس الاوكرانيه المسكي بما حمل توبيخا
ضنيا لمصر حسب صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه حيث دعى ذلك ماسك لزياره
اوكرانيا للاطلاع على الاضرار التي لحقت
بالبلاد من قبل القوات الروسيه وقطعبيره
رجل في العالم على فهم الوضع قبل الادلاء
بتصريحات حول الحرب وابقى قوله
وفي خطوه توعد بها سابقا الملياردير
الامريكي ومالك منصه تويتر الى مصر ضد
الحسابات المزيفه بدات تويتر بالفعل بحضره
تلك الحسابات حسبما نشر ماسك على موقع
تويتر ولفت رجل الاعمال الى ان تلك الخطوه
سينتج عنها خفض عدد المتابعين لاحقا قرر
ماسك في وقت سابق تاجيل استئنا في مبيعات
الشركات التحقق الى ان تقتنع اداره الموقع
بامكانيه منع المستخدمين من التحاليل صفه
الاخرين وفق قوله
[موسيقى]
وعامد ان استحوذ ماسك على تويتر يتواصلوا
الجدل الذي اثارته قراراته التغريبه
الاولى على تويتر للملياردير الامريكيه
الى مصر بعد امتلاكه المنصه كتب عباره
تحرير العصفور الذي فهم منها بان ماسك حقق
هدفه بتحويل المنصه الى ما وصفه بالمدينه
الرقميه حيث يمكن التعبير عن الاراء بحريه
كامله ومن ابرز تغريدات تعلقت بتعهد ماسك
امام ملايين من المستخدمين للموقع بانشاء
مجلس للرقابه على المحتوى يتكون من اطراف
الممثله لمختلف في وجهه النظر اما ازمه
التصريحات وجاءها مصر عبر الصمت في
البدايه الى انه عاده وبرر الامر بخسائر
يوميه لتويتر تصل الى حد اربعه ملايين
دولار ثم فاجا ماسكه اصحاب الحسابات على
منص دي بفكره حملت الكثير من الجدل والرد
بين المستخدمين وبين ماسك وتمثلت في منح
علامه التوثيق مقابل دفع اشتراك مالي لم
يتوقف الامر عند اعاده حساب الرئيس
الامريكي ترامب بالقرر مصر تفعيل جميع
الحسابات المحظوره على الشبكه على الشبكه
باستثناء البعض منها
المتفاخرون بالعنف ومن يستغلون الاطفال
اما اخر تغريدات مالك وتويتر حتى اللحظه
على الاقل فتعلقت بانهاء ما وصفه بسوء
الفهم مع شركه ابل فيما بدا انها تغريده
لطمئنتي مستخدمي موقع تويتر
وفي الولايات المتحده يواصلوا بركان
مانيلو ثورانه البركان الذي يوجد في جزيره
هاواي يعد اكبر بركانا نشط في العالم
الخامسه من العربيه انتهت ولكن خدمتنا
الاخباريه مستمره على راس الساعه دوما على
شاشه العربيه الى اللقاء